[Music]
he sold more than 170 million books
including one of our all-time favorites
the pillars of the earth
this week ken foley is out with a
prequel the evening and the morning
an epic tale about the world emerging
from the dark ages
it is once again signature fallette full
of history
architecture scandal and memorable
characters
from outside london we spoke to falet
about the evening and the morning
as well as the groundbreaking work he's
done in years past
sometimes people say i had given up on
reading
and i hadn't read a novel for 20 years
and then somebody gave me the pillars of
the the earth and they said you've
really got to read this book you've
really got to read this book
and i enjoyed it so much that it's got
me reading again
ken follett speaks with grandiosity
about pillars of the earth
which was later turned into a tv
miniseries i don't think kindly to
priests who steal
god doesn't take climate bishops who lie
but so do legions of its readers
who find its combination of storytelling
in history
a magical experience
now felit has traveled across the uk to
put together
the evening in the morning his prequel
to pillars
which opens with a savage viking
conquest in the year 997.
there's a mystique about vikings i think
that people are really fascinated by
but you make clear very quickly in this
book that these these are not the good
guys
people think the vikings are sexy and i
really don't
they were murderers thieves and
slavers and uh they were just the the
worst people in western europe
to write the evening and the morning
falet studied the bayou tapestry
a sort of comic book version of what
life was like at the end
of the dark ages they didn't have dogs
you wanted to go
aboard a ship you hitched up the skirts
of your tunic
around your waist and you walked through
the shallow water
if the information wasn't available he
got creative
for example in the evening in the
morning i did
everything i could to find out what
underwear people wore
in the dark ages or perhaps none but
perhaps some
and nobody knew so i made something up
and
and that's what you have to do
as usual in his fiction falette has
embraced strong characters
from all sides some books appeal more to
men and some books appeal more to women
one of the things about your books is
that i think there's been it's
it's always cut across those lines and
that was the goal i
i assume with this as well well
absolutely
and um when i was writing my first
successful book which was a wartime spy
story card eye of the needle
uh halfway through the planning process
i changed the main
character from a man to a woman because
everybody's read you know ten thrillers
about
two guys and it made the story much more
interesting
a decade after eye of the needle pillars
became an even bigger publishing
phenomenon
in part by leaving almost nothing out of
bounds
you've never shied away from the carnal
aspects
of life in your books why is that it's
partly because i and my readers like the
carnal aspects of life but there is a
literary reason as well
there's often in a a novel
there's a love story in which two people
are crazy about one another but they
can't be together
and whatever the reason that's the story
if two people meet and fall in love and
get married and live happily ever after
it's not a story is it
but if you have had these two people for
two or three hundred pages looking at
one another over a crowded room
wishing they could be alone together
wishing that they could kiss but not
being allowed to kiss
and then finally comes the moment
when they can be together they're alone
together they can do
all the things that they've been
dreaming about
for the last 300 pages then it's only
fair to the reader that we should go
with them just for a little way at least
into their paradise there was no king
there was no queen there is no law in
this land
falet's epic ancient tales have never
been easy to transfer to television
but that hasn't stopped filmmakers from
trying when do we see the evening in the
morning
on a screen well wouldn't that be nice
it would be an expensive show to make
but uh
i can just see it it opens with a big
dramatic
action scene i i'm hoping hollywood will
love it
the evening and the morning he is fun to
talk to you right now i love him
by the way even just describing the
carnal nature i was like
what yeah i mean like i was there it's
crazy he's fun to talk to he's also a
master storyteller
and the books are really tough to put
down he is a character
he really truly is and we thank you for
sitting down with us such a great story